Elden ring has an optional tutorial now
so you can actually just turn off those
annoying tutorial pop-ups in the
settings and just watch this video and
be free free to go off and die in a
ditch somewhere first charge attacks in
Olden ring they're so powerful they're
so good and I know just who to test them
on
Maiden does runt who do you think
so charge attacks being powerful that's
one thing but what's really important
for you to know is that so many
different types of attack can be charged
now of course weapon r2s can be charged
for more damage and more posture damage
and even some L2 weapon skills can be
charged like the glint sword
and by holding R1 you can now also
charge your spells what's special about
this is that charged variants of spells
often have more than just a damage
multiplier some like dragon fire can be
channeled longer others like bubbles
persist longer in the world when they're
charged and when I used rejection I
noticed that its regular R1 didn't
Dismount enemies but it's charge attack
did experiment with charged magic learn
it fully because these charged spells
actually cost the exact same amount of
FP as their regular variants therefore
you know if you do have time to charge
an attack or spell you probably should
another thing to get in the habit of is
crafting which you can do as soon as you
buy the crafting kit from kale after a
few hours of play you should have
accumulated a few recipe books to expand
your crafting options and if you've been
hunting and foraging between bosses then
you'll be able to make quite a few items
here pay attention to which material
drops that you're finding in the world
it'll make it that tiny bit easier to
get more of that specific thing when you
realize you need it to craft an item you
need the crafting page gives you hints
at where to find specific materials and
from what I can tell all World materials
seem to respawn instantly upon resting
at a Grace making them fairly easy to
farm and if there's one thing you do
want to farm in this game it's the
ingredients for Sleep arrows these
things are so crazy good and you know
it's something that new players and
especially experienced players will
sleep on one of the most interesting
materials are cracked pots they're these
containers materials that you need to
make Throne consumables like fire bombs
or sleep pots these cracked pots are
magical they go back into your inventory
after you've thrown the item you made
with them that means if I buy three pots
I can craft three fire bombs but I can
only craft three more fire bombs if I
throw the three that I've already made
so remember they're a container they're
not a consumable technically and I
reckon it's likely that throughout the
game you will accumulate more of these
containers meaning you can carry a
higher maximum of fire bombs or sleep
pots or whatever and I wonder if there's
more materials that function in this way
now I didn't use any craftable items on
my first playthrough and you know that
was a mistake I played this like it was
sekito I was stubborn and determined to
beat the first boss with my
under-leveled underpowered character who
was wielding a weapon that I didn't
really like so don't make that same
mistake remember Elden Ring's a bit
different if something is giving you
trouble you don't just have to get good
instead you can take a step back and
remember that there are creative ways
around your problem
the first thing you want to consider are
Spirit summons that these powerful
companions that can be found throughout
the world I get the impression that
these will work differently in the full
game but for now they're items that use
FP and are able to be equipped to your
quick select bar in the equipment menu
they're able to be summoned in any area
that has this little Obelisk but that's
not what you should be looking for
instead if you're in a difficult area
you'll know because this icon will pop
up on the left letting you know that you
can summon your spirits some Spirits
like the noble sorcerer are a sort of
ranged DPS others like the wolves are
melee Fighters with a lot of Mobility so
some Spirits are designed to tank for
you and others it's sort of implied that
you're supposed to distract enemies from
them and if you're a Faith Build you can
even consider healing your spirits
between battles with a heal spell hell
you can even heal them during battle
with that heal spell that's how fast you
can cast this thing so if you're really
having trouble decide on the best Spirit
to suit to the situation and try to
overcome it that way and if you fail
well if a fight is difficult enough to
Warrant Spirits then it likely has a
stake of Marika as well that's this
statue if you're within its range then
you'll be able to choose it as a respawn
Point upon death and if you find one of
these in a cave then you can expect to
find a boss very soon basically they're
just here to prevent a long run back
from a sight of Grace and they're easy
to miss but again you shouldn't be
looking for the Statue instead you
should be looking for this little icon
in the top left if that icon is active
then you're within range of one try to
make use of all of Elden Ring's
mechanics to stay alive don't just play
it like it's one of their previous games
because one of their biggest additions
to combat are guard counters so now
after you block an attack whether it's
with a shield or a two-handed weapon you
can follow up with a strong R2
accompanied by this sound effect
these attacks come out fast they deal
good damage and most importantly
enormous posture damage the amount of
times you'll stagger an enemy after
doing this is insane if you use these
and other attacks to break an enemy's
invisible posture meter then you'll be
able to knock them down for a Critical
Strike so if you have a powerful shield
and you're confident that an enemy has
just used the last attack in their combo
and they've hit you with it then you
have so much to gain from using a guard
counter and even if you're two-handing
your weapon guard counters give you a
reason to block they're that good
so Elden ring uses X or a as a jump
button which means that interact has
moved up to the triangle or Y button
which means that the two handing input
has changed for you as well now to
two-hand weapon or a shield you have to
hold triangle or Y and then tap R1 or L1
R1 two hands your weapon on the right L1
two hands the weapon on your left it's a
bit jarring at first but this is
actually a really nice input it's fast
and it lets you quickly to hand either
weapon not just one of them two handing
weapons increases your damage output and
like in previous games it probably lets
you get around a lack of a strength stat
in many cases additionally two handing
is even stronger in Elden ring because
of that new posture system that I've
mentioned a few times now a two-handed
weapon will inflict greater posture
damage to your enemies especially if you
use R2 and especially if you charge
those r2s or if you use R2 jumping
attacks or those R2 guard counters
basically if fighting an enemy with a
really big HP pool and the fight's gonna
go on for a while it's worth weaving in
these r2s or two-handing your weapon if
you sense that you're getting close to
breaking their posture to handing a
weapon also gives you access to its
assigned skill a weapon skill is
something that you activate with L2 and
the current one you will perform is
always written here on the left side of
the screen it's actually really great to
have that reminder as these are powerful
and you don't want to not use them most
armaments come with a default skill
though some items intended for your left
hand actually don't and that's because
sometimes you want the skill to default
to whatever's in your main hand in some
cases skills are unique and they're
locked to their weapon but in most cases
they aren't and can be changed with
ashes of War so when you sit at a Grace
select the ash of War option and here
you'll see all your basic weapons but
also bows catalysts talismans and
shields remember to give them ashes of
War as well barricade for example is an
incredible War for your Shield the other
thing assigning these does is it allows
you to choose some scaling options so if
you're an intelligence build you'll want
to choose magic so that your weapon
starts to scale with your intelligence
stat so be sure to pick the scaling that
best suits your stat and also remember
to take ashes of War off your weapon if
you're not using it anymore last thing I
want to mention is that kick is still in
this game the input has just changed now
kick is an L2 skill and it can be
performed when your bare fists are out
it functions really similarly to Dark
Souls actually it punishes enemies
severely if they have their Shield up
apart from that it doesn't seem to deal
much if any posture damage seeing a
return in Elden ring as well is power
stancing which allows you to draw
additional benefit from dual wielding as
long as both weapons that you have
equipped are of the same type so here
for example I have two great swords even
though one of them is The Crucible
Greatsword and the other one is a a
Bastard Sword both are great swords so
both can be power stanced when I tap L1
I attack with both weapons dramatically
increasing my damage and giving me
access to a really really powerful
moveset some of these move sets just
like your R1 and R2 movesets some of
them can go up to like three or four or
five attack combos it's great this L1
attack can also be used in running
attacks but the most important thing I
think is that you can do power stanced
L1 jumping attacks these are
particularly useful while power stancing
because these are a high Mobility attack
and when you're holding two weapons
Mobility is everything it's your
defensive asset as well as your
offensive asset and being able to jump
attack makes it both this is also a
great time to mention that your jump
also has iframes it allows you to dodge
through enemy attacks and attack at the
same time so just think about how good
that is you can literally jump into an
enemy and be invincible and attack mid
attack of course you don't even need to
power stand to do this every weapon has
access to R1 and even heavy R2 jumping
attacks as well one of the best ways to
utilize jumping attacks is off the back
of your Mount Dismount with L3 and slam
them with L1 R1 or R2 the distance you
can cover with this is absurd and
initiating a fight in this way gives you
this immediate advantage over your
opponents you can Dismount with the same
whistle item you used to mount up but
I'd recommend getting into the habit of
using L3 instead since you'll commonly
quick swap off the whistle item in order
to heal for example Crimson flasks heal
your character while you're on Horseback
but they don't heal your Mount which can
take significant damage as well Torrance
health bar is pretty enormous but if a
fight goes on long enough it is possible
for him to die if this happens you'll
have to sacrifice a crimson flask to
revive him instead if you notice torrent
taking a ton of damage just heal him
instead said rower berries easily found
throughout the world can be used to
craft rower raisins which can be fed to
torrent while mounted what's going to
happen before torrent dies is that
you're gonna get knocked off your horse
that's way more likely this is done when
your posture is broken and it puts you
in a vulnerable state on the ground for
a really really long time you're gonna
feel it because you can get hit while
you're down here it's devastating I
think the rule is if you've been hit a
few times on Horseback it's time to get
off before things get worse but while
mounted you can double jump to get over
more terrain you can also Sprint to move
across it more quickly interesting thing
about the Sprint is that you don't have
to hold Circle to Sprint you just have
to tap it tapping it also gives you a
burst of speed in exchange for stamina
so remember to spam the sprint button
when you're desperately trying to outrun
something and of course while you're out
of combat sprinting doesn't consume
stamina at all while you're mounted R1
and R2 give you the light and heavy
attacks on the right side and L1 and L2
give light and heavy attacks on the left
side if you hold your heavy attacks you
can also charge them for a little while
in order to properly time their release
what's most interesting here is that
most weapons seem to have active
hitboxes while you're charging the
attack some like the Lance seem to have
a much higher hitbox which I think is
good for mounted enemies and others like
the great sword are dragged along the
ground and seem excellent for
dispatching grounded enemies the twin
blade on the other hand does seem to
have a pretty inconsistent hitbox while
it's spinning but it's possible that
there are advantages and disadvantages
to each there are a variety of ways to
take out other enemies on Horseback you
can Target and kill their horse and then
fight the enemy alone or you can Target
them on Horseback and kill them while
their horse is still wandering some
enemies can be instantly knocked off
with sleep arrows which is amazing
although horses do seem to be immune to
sleep or you can knock them off with
certain spells that deal a ton of
posture damage now all of this is well
and good but we all know the most
stylish way to take out a mounted enemy
is this a well-timed Parry
so this black Horseman can only be
fought at night he patrols the bridge
back and forth and it's in exactly the
same manner as another Horseman does
during daytime I actually camped out
here for a full day to try and see if
this daytime night transforms into the
night night and he does but there's no
transformation animation like I was
hoping for so this brings me to the day
and night system in Elton ring a full
day and night takes exactly one hour to
pass I know this because I sat and timed
the whole thing the sun rises and sets
in real time rain starts rain stops and
all of it is just this fantastic
addition to the game that really makes
the world feel alive but the true test
of this system is going to be its
gameplay implications and so far there
are a few we mentioned the Black Knight
but bats also spawn in at more locations
during night time and overall night
seems like it's going to contain more
difficult enemies so if you prefer you
can sit at a Grace and pass time until
morning instead but one benefit tonight
that we know about so far is that it
seems to buff your stealth so if your
plan is to sneak into a camp perhaps to
grab a valuable item like the map
fragment in this area then that's
another excellent reason to set your
time of day at the grace checkpoint the
same dial that shows up here can also be
found anytime on your map screen where
it's even more specific about the time
of day where it tells you if it's
morning or afternoon or evening and so
on the results of my tests are on screen
and as you can see here this enemy spots
me here during the daytime and the same
enemy spots me here at night
and if you get really close to some
enemies you might be able to overhear
s yep I knew it he's listening to an
audiobook with audible right now for a
limited time you can save 46 on your
first four months of audible that makes
it only 7.95 a month give yourself the
gift of listening for more go to
audible.com vati video or text varti
video to 500 to 500. I love taking these
sponsorships because I love recommending
audiobooks and this time I'm
recommending June which is a sci-fi
classic that has recently again been
turned into a feature film it's the best
audiobook I've ever listened to I feel
like because it features at times
ambient music to suit the mood and even
multiple voice actors for the cast of
characters have a listen I've been
studying about the storms on a Ruckus
storms
I see
they sound pretty bad
it's too close as a word bad
those stones build up across six or
seven thousand kilometers of Flat Lands
feed on anything that can give them a
push coriolis Force other storms
anything that has an ounce of energy in
it
they can blow up to 700 kilometers an
hour loaded with everything loose that's
in their way sand dust everything
they can eat flesh off bones and etch
the bones to slivers I'm personally
listening to June right now so that I
can go and enjoy the new movie
afterwards and maybe a lot of you will
too anyway whether you want to listen to
this or anything from the huge selection
go to audible.com variety video or text
varti video to 500 to 500 and thank you
as always for watching